hace dos años Cuba vivió el mayor
movimiento social de contestación desde
la revolución de Fidel Castro en 1959
miles de cubanos salieron a las calles
de casi 50 ciudades gritando tenemos
hambre o libertad bastante porque es que
no sé el pueblo no está alterado porque
no hay comida porque hay problema y para
todos una situación y para todo es una
cosa el presidente Miguel yazcanel acusó
a Estados Unidos de organizar la
protesta para desestabilizar el país
pero también hay un grupo de gente
contrarevolucionaria mercenaria pagada
por el gobierno de los Estados Unidos
pagado indirectamente a través de
agencias del gobierno norteamericano
para armar este tipo de manifestación el
gobierno reprimió las protestas en
mayoría pacíficas y detuvo a más de
1.500 personas según varias ongs cientos
de personas fueron encarceladas
algunas con penas de prisión de hasta 30
años por sedición Marta perdomo que vive
a 30 km de La Habana sigue pidiendo
justicia para sus dos hijos detenidos
por haber participado en las marchas
estos dos años desde el comienzo dejé
ese primer día
que se los llevaron
ya empezó ese dolor ese dolor como no sé
quién le dije hace unos días ese dolor
amanece
atardece y anochece quizás hicieron el
crimen más grande que se pudiera hacer
pedir libertad dos años después de las
protestas las condiciones de vida de los
cubanos no han mejorado actualmente se
enfrentan a varios problemas como la
falta de acceso al agua en la capital o
a largos cortes de electricidad